hey everybody my name is Martin McGovern
I'm a career advisor here Udacity and I
apologize for keeping you all waiting we
had a bit of a schedule snafu and this
was our first week changing the date or
that were changing the time of day that
we were gonna be broadcasting these so I
apologize for any and all of you that
we're waiting for us to jump on and do a
little QA at this point if you have any
questions that you'd like us to jump
into we'll do a few minutes here for
those of you that did join and I really
do appreciate you joining us we have
Karen in the chat and she'll be sending
over any of you the questions that are
top of your mind right now and hopefully
we can address a couple of the things
that you're thinking about and if if we
don't get if if we've missed it and
there aren't any questions well we'll
just wrap up and try again next week and
I do thank you for joining and apologize
for the change in time and and what
happened here so I'll keep an eye out
for Karen and see if there are any
questions that have popped up in the
chat that we can jump into
alright looks like we might have a
question coming through no questions
alright well let's see here I'm going to
see if any questions are coming through
all right we got one thank you for
joining us and thank you for asking
questions our first one is I've made a
career change from construction manager
to data science how do I pitch myself
it's a really great question and I think
one of the things that we want to keep
in mind when we're thinking about
pitching ourselves is we want to include
the entire story of our work history we
don't want to just ignore the past and
focus on the future we want to connect
all the dots so when you're thinking
about you know coming from the
construction world as a construction
manager what are the what are the things
that you did in that role that relate to
your work in data science what we want
to keep in mind here is you know as a
construction manager you probably spend
a lot of time problem-solving you
probably spend a lot of time working
with people and trying to come up with
interesting solutions as a team
collaboration different things like that
and what you can do is say here's why I
was interested in construction I like to
build things I like to do X Y & Z and
here's why I'm really interested in data
science and you can make those
connections at your past skills into
your current environment so as you're
thinking about pitching yourself we
might want to get a little more nuanced
and exactly how are you pitching
yourself are you pitching yourself as a
at a networking event in an interview of
course it's gonna change you differ
depending on you know what you're doing
at the moment but what we can do is say
you know I have a background in this I
think one of the ways that I've said it
in past is like with a background in
construction management merge or merging
a background in construction management
with my current focus on data science
I'm able to solve these types of
problems for people and that's just a
really fun way to pitch yourself so for
me it'd be like with a background or
merging my background in marketing with
my current focus on career development
I'm able to help people not only handle
the emotional but also the promotional
parts of the job search so I'd be one
way to pitch
merging the the backgrounds together all
right we have another question here from
row Heat how can I get my first
internship that's a great question and
most internships aren't gonna be posted
online most are going to be a
relationship that you develop with
someone that leads to you coming in and
helping them out I think certain states
they aren't allowed to do free
internships I believe in California you
have to pay interns so what you want to
do is you want to go and build those
relationships figure out what problems a
company has maybe it's scheduling maybe
it's they just need someone to help with
like some basic tasks that are going out
on the team and then say I can help you
with those basic things so you can go
focus on the bigger things right
everyone has busy work that needs to get
done so if you can help take some of the
low-hanging fruit off of their plate and
free up their time to go do bigger
bigger and better things you can very
easily get an internship so even if
there's nothing posted I think the best
way to find an internship is to go chat
with managers and try and find out like
you know what how many hours a week what
they need help and see if you could be
the person that fills that spot so it's
going to come down to networking it's
going to come down to asking a lot of
good questions while doing informational
interviews kind of mining for their
struggles I think some of the questions
that are good to ask are like what is
what are some of the things you're most
excited about and also what are some of
the things that you're struggling with
and you what you can do with those
answers is say well they're really
excited about this big project so I want
to help them with that big project maybe
I can come on and support them in some
way or they're really struggling with
this project well that means they need
some more hands on deck how can I go in
and help so if you approach it from that
perspective I think you might really
increase your chances of finding an
internship
all right we got some new questions
coming - thank you so much for joining
us by the way in being patient and
asking these great questions as we jump
on the call here as someone who never
had a job in data science should I apply
for a job in data science or an
internship it's a really good question I
think one of the things that you want to
keep in mind is what is your background
right how much experience cuz experience
can be interpreted in number of
different ways
there's hands-on experience with the
route with the job at hand right but the
interesting thing about that is that a
lot of the lot of times when we're
applying for a job even if we've been
working in that field
we don't have experience in the job
we're applying for so we have to
translate some of our other experience
hands that prepared us to do this and so
you know I would say go after
entry-level and internship roles
especially if you're open to doing both
and then just see what see what happens
I figured out by trial and error if
you're going and you're applying for all
these things and you're not getting the
role when they say we actually don't
have availability for a full-time
entry-level position or you don't meet
the qualifications you can just hit them
right back and say alright while I don't
have the qualifications for the
full-time role is are there any openings
for interns maybe I can come in a few
hours a week and just start showing
value right and so if you can't get that
role so you can get a role that leads to
it all right
sunny asks hi I'm going to have a zoom
interview tomorrow and the role I'm
going for requires experience in handing
handling large scale marketing budgets I
don't have the experience with large
budgets what do I do thank you for
question that's a really good one what
have you done in regards to financial
management either personally or within a
company have you ever had any sort of
constraints around budgeting in your
personal or professional life if maybe
you don't have large-scale budget
experience but you know maybe you've
gotten yourself out of debt
maybe you've um you know worked hard on
your family's personal finances if they
ask
keep questions about finances you just
talked about the relevant information
that you do have and if you truly don't
have any experience with what with
budgeting at all you say that's an area
that I'm not currently strong in but I'm
working to develop that skill through X
Y & Z maybe don't say I'm not strong and
maybe say like that's an area in which
I'm continually trying to get more
experience and here's what I'm doing to
get that experience personally I'm
reading these things I'm doing these
things maybe these are the these are the
financial blogs that I follow and then
say and I'm really excited to work with
a team and figure out how to do that and
I think one of the things is they might
put that in the job description but it
might actually be a pretty small part of
the role depending on you know what this
role is so you can ask them like how
important or how what percentage of my
role would be managing the budget and
what and is that something we do as a
team is that something I do on my own
you can ask questions about it as well
and so that's that might be helpful way
to approach it rather than a yes or no
approach it from a more curiosity a more
curious perspective more trying to
figure out what what gaps you need to
fill in order to be able to do that job
right alright John I finished a
self-driving car nanodegree how can I
know what level of job I should be
applying with my skill set a lot of jobs
require a bachelor's or master's and I'm
not sure how to nd compares this is a
great question we actually have two
questions around this the best thing you
can do is find the job that you want to
have put it into LinkedIn under there
people search find people in your area
so you can actually filter on LinkedIn's
people search for job title and location
and then reach out to those people and
ask them questions about your
qualifications and what is needed in
order to get that job so they'll be able
to give you the insights you need to
know because every company is different
some companies have high requirements
companies have pretty open requirements
it all depends on the company and the
role so you need to go talk with people
who are doing those jobs in order to
find out if you're going to be able to
qualify for that entry-level role or if
you need to do an internship or you need
to do something else of that sort
alright we got a question from Mustafa
I'm afraid to spend time learning any
technology then it gets old and replaced
with another what should I do well
Mustafa we live in a technologically
shifting world everything gets old and
gets replaced whether it is you know
Photoshop for designers gets replaced by
the next version or just the software
and your computer getting updated if
you're scared of learning anything
because it's going to be replaced you
might as well put the computer away and
not even learn anything in the first
place we have to make change part of our
learning process we can never get
stagnant so whenever we go into learning
something new we go into it with the
mindset of this will eventually be
replaced by something else and you see
this all the time when people are
working at a company and they get
complacent and then they never upgrade
their software for a while right the
computer starts to get slow they never
upgrade so what ends up happening is
when they have to apply for that next
job they're out of date and they haven't
kept up with the changes of technology
make keeping up with the changes in
technology part of your learning process
that way you'll always be a competitive
candidate for new roles and new jobs if
you're still using Lotus Notes instead
of Gmail you might be a bit behind on
the technological curve right and we I
was using Lotus Notes almost a decade
ago in my first job and we were even 5
to 10 years behind where the industry
was using Outlook at the lead and so
what ends up happening is when I go into
my next role and everyone's on
new software I have to learn anyway I
have to relearn everything anyway so I
hope that you work on that fear in order
to make changes in technology part of
your learning process rather than
something that you know you fear or
resist doing we have another question
from Rohit should I go for a master's
degree or a job after graduating from
computer science this is a really good
question and while I can't say
specifically what you should do I will
give a little bit of context around this
concept that I've seen a lot of people
living out the the idea is productive
procrastination a lot of times when I
talk to people who are going back to
school they're not doing it because they
want to learn they're doing it because
they want to procrastinate they're
saying well I need more education well
the truth is we always need more
education there's literally never a time
in your life where you shouldn't be
learning something new so if we are
constantly just learning new things
learning new things and learning new
things we can put off the job search
forever and the truth of the matter is
that eventually you have to stop
learning and start doing if we are
constantly procrastinating doing then we
are not moving forward in life
so when people are asking should I go
learn something new
typically I'll say like is this required
for your next move if it's not required
make the next move because experience
will always win over education so I'm
not sure what you should do in this
situation necessarily but I would I
would really go talk to some people who
are doing the job that you want to do
and ask them that the master's degree is
is a hundred percent necessary they
might surprise you and say no it's not
necessary and then you can just get
right into the job search we have a
question from Devin I have found most of
the autonomous vehicle positions seem to
be geared to university internships with
masters or PhD degrees seems like my
many years I
is a disadvantage how do I handle
applying this is a great question Devin
I think a lot of this comes down to
building a network if someone knows who
you are your credentials become a little
bit more fluid let's say because they
can see that you can bring value to a
team and that you can learn quickly and
that you can grow even if you don't have
the PhD or something like that and maybe
that role isn't exactly the role you can
get but you can find something else that
does fit your experience so I think the
best way to get around all these worries
about credentials is to go talk to real
people and build your network because
I'll tell you when I'm talking with
people who don't have a PhD they're
always complaining that the companies
want to hire people with PhDs and then
when I talk to people with PhDs they're
complaining that all the companies want
to hire people who don't have PhDs
because they're less expensive and so
everyone thinks the grass is greener on
the other side of the fence when in
reality if you just skip worrying about
all that stuff and go talk to real
people and try to solve problems you're
going to stand out and you're going to
find an opportunity well I'm loving that
all these questions are coming and I
appreciate you guys hanging on and
asking awesome questions all right
this question is from Osama to work in a
software company do I need a degree or
certificate it's just too broad of a
question the truth of the matter is is
that every company utilizes technology
now every company is a tech company and
if they're not they're falling behind so
with so many different types of
companies in so many different parts of
the world there really is no answer of
do I need a degree or certificate
the truth of the matter is is that some
companies will require degrees some
companies only need certificates and
there are might may be even smaller
companies one person to versus shops
they don't care at all they just care
can you get the job done
so I would again recommend this is going
to be a case-by-case basis and you're
not going to know unless you go talk to
and ask people that work at that company
what the requirements are for that job
so get get the education you need and
then start trying to find opportunities
to help people because that's really
what's gonna make you stand out is your
ability to communicate solve problems
and help alright well we got through a
lot of great questions I know the timing
got a little bit messed up today so I
apologize for anyone who is waiting
anyone who was you know a little
frustrated that the call didn't start
right when we were hoping it would but I
appreciate you hanging on and I
appreciate you asking these really
amazing questions it's been an absolute
blast you know going through some of
these things with you and really you
know figuring out what it is it's on
your mind and how we can help you find
the job that you want all right and I
think I'm gonna wrap up with our final
question here and then we'll be signing
off from among hey do you have any
advice on starting a first job in
programming it's a very broad question
any advice about starting a first job in
programming do you mean about finding a
first job in programming or actually you
have one and now you're starting your
job I'll give a little bit umple if
you're trying to find a job
are a few basic things that you really
need to do that will set you apart from
other applicants the first thing is
realize that 80% of jobs are found
through personal connections so if
you're only applying to job boards it's
going to be an endless black hole of non
responses and rejections with only maybe
one to four percent of the things that
you send out really turning into
opportunities that means if you want to
get a job you're going to have to send
hundreds and hundreds of applications
through those portals in order to get
the response level that you need so what
you want to do is move beyond the
portals and start networking if you are
networking for a job you are immediately
going to be standing out against your
competition and what you need to do is
reach out to people who are doing the
job that you wish you are doing if you
talk to those people learn what their
problems are and offer solutions you
will stand out amongst everyone and then
once you do get the job what I would
recommend that you do is sit down with
your manager and set a 1 3 and 6 month
goal for what you should be able to
accomplish in the first half of the year
that you're there so you can literally
ask them one month now what do you hope
that I can do will I still be in
training will I be you know on my own
working out projects at what point do
you want to see me hit certain levels of
competency in this job so if you do that
you'll start standing out from the other
employees at your company as well all
right I think we have two more questions
so I'm going to try and cover those in
in our time left the first one is from
nabilla
in Saudi Arabia hello I'm 42 years old
and I want to change my career from
front-end user support to artificial
intelligence and machine learning is
this a good idea it's interesting is
this a good idea well I guess it depends
on what you're hoping to do for the next
how many years are you
typically people who retire around 65 to
75 so you're 42 so you've got 20 to 30
years if not more left in your career
it's a lot of time so yeah I I would
personally if it's something that
interests you and making gets you
excited and you you'd rather do that for
the next 20 years rather than what
you're doing right now I see absolutely
no reason why you shouldn't make a
career change in that direction now we
have to also be realistic that you know
ageism is a thing in the tech world I
know there's a lot of articles that are
being written about that right now so
you're gonna want to really work on
building a strong network and building
those connections in order to be able to
make this move in a clean way in order
to be able to you know transition
seamlessly from one thing to another but
I think that artificial intelligence and
machine learning are gonna be really
interesting areas to explore over the
next 20 years so if that's something
you're excited about I see no reason not
to all right our next question is from
Al my training to become a full-stack
developer is taking longer than I'd like
should I just apply for front-end
developer positions I don't want to be
offered low pay what is the best
strategy hmm well I guess my first
question is how long did you expect it
to take and why is it taking longer than
you thought is it taking longer than you
thought because it's actually not
something you want to pursue and you
know where you at in your career if like
I was saying in this last question you
know we typically work until we're 70
plus so wherever you're at in your
career if it's quote unquote taking too
long maybe we need to take a bit of a
bigger you know a more a longer term
view of what our career trajectory looks
like if getting to be a full stack
developer is truly
you want then I would not recommend
making that shift because you're going
to limit your opportunities in the
future based off of impatience and that
seems like it would be a limiting factor
for just you know it's good to be
patient it's good to work hard it's good
to learn so I'm not quite sure why you'd
want to limit yourself in that way now
if you need a job because of
circumstances and and you really need an
income and you don't want to spend more
time learning and you need to get to
work I understand that as well
in that case you know go after the job
that you need to go after I think this
is really going to come down to what are
your priorities is your priority which
it seems like from this question is your
priority pay people or skill set and so
a lot of people their priority is skill
set I talk I you know I work with a lot
of filmmakers and their priority is to
become a great filmmaker they'll get
paid less and they'll work with anyone
because their priority is to learn how
to make great films now for someone else
those priorities might be different pay
is more important than the people or the
position and in that case they would
work a number of different types of
roles with a number of different types
of people in order to make that certain
amount of money you might think like
fine mance would be a good way to think
about that someone who wants to work as
a stockbroker or something like that
they might prioritize the amount that
they make over the environment like the
coolness of the environment where as
someone who's younger who wants to be an
intern might put the environment over
the other two things they might really
want to work at a cool hip startup and
put you know the place over the position
and the pay they might get paid a little
less work different roles but they're
around interesting people and
interesting places so I guess it really
comes down to you know what are your
goals here what are you hoping to
accomplish and I think the best strategy
is the one that thinks long-term so
don't think about the next you know the
immediate paycheck in the immediate job
think about where you want to be in five
years and what's going to help you get
there
all right we got a couple more questions
here I'm from Brazil
Luciano I'm from Brazil and I'm an
Android developer I have a lot of
difficulty finding a job how can I show
these companies that I exist and I do
what I do this is gonna come down to
your online presence when I google you
what comes up do you own your own domain
name do you have a portfolio that's easy
to view and easy to see do you have a
LinkedIn that is properly put together
do you have projects on github or
elsewhere that I can see and I won't
even take it a step further are you
engaging with other people where these
conversations are happening are you
commenting on posts are you writing
articles of your own are you showcasing
your skillset in any way the online
brand your personal brand is the most
important piece of your career if you're
not developing your personal brand over
the long term then it is going to be
very hard for people to find you and
understand your value because you if
let's let's put it this way if you make
if you write a bunch of articles have a
really great online presence a website
and maybe even some videos when I google
you and I go through all that I already
get to know you before we we talk in
person so then at the interview I have a
pretty good sense of who you are when
you come in I can ask you questions we
can go deep but if I've never met you
before there's nothing about you online
and you walk into the interview we only
have a half hour for me to get to know
you so having a great online presence
expands the amount of time someone has
to get to know you and trust you and
that's really what we're trying to build
when we're trying to get a job we're
trying to build trust with the people
that we're talking with and so if you
can build trust you can really make a
dent in your potential opportunities you
can really open up the doors alright
we're coming to the end of the hour here
so I'm going to have to wrap up I want
to just make sure I covered everything
all right so there's a couple more
questions that I think we would really
wrap up is just saying patience
incredibly important during the job
search when you're feeling really rushed
and you're feeling really anxious take a
step back and try and practice patience
because patience is what's going to
really help you and you know weather the
storms and the ups and downs of the job
search the job search is a pretty brutal
process so if you feel like it sucks I
feel yeah it's supposed to so just
really own the fact that everyone is
struggling it's not just you and try and
be a little bit patient and a little bit
more understanding because most of the
time they are not trying to personally
attack you or make you feel bad they
just have a lot going on and they're
doing their best
so always assume good intentions be
patient and good luck in all of your job
search pursuits and if you have any
other questions I know we had a short
session today please reach out via
LinkedIn be a slack via you know career
support at Udacity and let us know any
questions you have I'm happy to go in
more depth and we will be seeing you
next week when we read when we do this
one more time or not one more time when
we continue to do this on a weekly basis
I look forward to chatting with you
again soon thank you so much have a
great rest of the day